what's going on guys this is Rob and I
apologize if it's a little yellowy in
here usually I use natural light to
record on my camera and it's 11 o'clock
at night so there's no natural light
outside because you know the Sun sets so
because of that uh bear with me here
anyway
ah so so infinity war alright in god
this movie was was good I still say the
Winter Soldier is better like Captain
America too I think is better but in
terms of in terms of this ok seriously
oh this review is gonna have spoilers
because a spoiler free review would
basically come down to it was good
thanks for watching guys peace like this
basically would be a spoiler free review
ah so this video is gonna have spoilers
that being said ah dude this movie was
was crazy good I mean it was it was
amazing uh and to kick all this off the
one thing everybody wants to know uh who
dies play who all dies in this movie
well technically speaking it'd be easier
to list the people who don't die as
opposed to listing the people who do
which by the way hopefully the video is
not too blurry because you know anyway
the number of people who died is it's
easier to list the number of people who
don't dive in the people who do but to
make it easy uh
alright so um start at the top guardians
of the galaxy
we say let's say come or Gamora dies
Drax to destroy your dies I don't think
Peter quill dies group dies and so
Rocket Raccoon and I think Peter quill
are left alive and then of course what's
your name
nebula survives moving on to the ax to
the black order they all die everybody
in the black order dies we'll talk about
the black order here in a second because
I'm not really sure I like what they did
with a black order uh as for the
Avengers well a couple more characters
Maria Hill dies Nick Fury dies you don't
see captain Kevin Marvel anywhere in the
movie you just kind of get like Nick
Fury sitting out there's only one
post-credit scene by the way you get
Nick Fury sending out a message kind of
like oh my god everything's popping off
and it just shows the Captain Marvel
logo and it's like well that's
disappointing I really wanted to see
brie Larson because she looked amazing
in the photos so like I really wanted to
see her like as Captain Marvel close
like brie Larson is a beautiful woman so
I think she'll play the world really
really well um alright now moving on to
the Avengers
alright well actually yeah I guess we
can kind of count them
Avenger Black Panther dies Peter Parker
dies Doctor Strange dies um let's see
who else Bucky Barnes dies uh I'll try
to remember who else dies all mantis
dies and guardians of the galaxy by the
way I don't know if we said her like all
the wakandan forces died
what gorilla actually survives believe
it or not um Captain America lives Tony
Stark lives basically all the like the
really popular ones live but they they
called a ton of them I think out of out
of the combination of the guardians of
the galaxy the Avengers and all the
other ancillary superheroes that we've
seen along the way I think something
like seven died Scarlet Witch dies
vision dies of course everybody expected
vision to die uh it's it's nice like
Scarlet Witch goes out like a hero like
it's it's crazy okay now onto onto the
to this stuff about Thanos alright so I
like what they did but I don't like what
they did okay
Thanos is a guy in Marvel Comics who's
just he's a nihilist he believes death
is meaningless
I'm sorry life is meaningless any
warships mistress death you will not see
her in this movie at all she's nowhere
to be found
they kind of allude to it you know in
the sense of like he you know wipes out
half of because he snaps his fingers and
half the life the universe gets
obliterated and then you see like you
see like like him just kind of talking
to like basically Gamora when she was a
little girl and it's like you know what
did it cost and so it's coming maybe he
experienced the afterlife we don't
really know but you don't see like
mistress death which is to say the skull
are like the super hot chick with a
cloak over her head you don't see any of
that so that's that's kind of a weird
thing and said that his whole goal in
the movie is well heat like these like
well you know I believe that the
universe is Annabelle's so if you ever
read Marvel the end that's kind of what
they borrowed from um he believes the
universe is out of balance and because
there's just too much life and so he's
like we're just gonna call half-life in
the universe because it's the only way
to balance things and what he's been
doing is traveling around planets and
wiping out half the planets population
so that's that's kind of a weird thing
um the blood the way he does it is cool
like I mean he dominates the superheroes
quite readily I mean it's it's not much
of a fight but they did kind of hold
their own for example there's a fight on
Titan where you have Iron Man and the
guardians of the galaxy and - Gamora
and they also have nebula there and
Doctor Strange and yes spider Manistee
we sent him uh and they kind of like
hold their own uh technically that
shouldn't happen like like Danno should
have just decimated them all like just
crush them all easily um he's I think
that in the movie he's nerve quite
drastically from the comics I mean even
Thanos without the Infinity Gauntlet
could crush the Avengers like they're
not much of a challenge for because he's
just so powerful and because he's so
durable um if one of the cool displays
is in the beginning of the movie those
of you guys who guessed in the beginning
of the movie that basically it's like an
all-out assault on on the Asgardian ship
and they basically all get crushed then
you're right about that there's one
point where we're like Thanos fights the
Hulk it only lasts for about five
minutes and the Hulk gets the upper hand
for like 30 seconds and for like the
next four and a half minutes like Thanos
is just crushing it it's not really four
and half minutes it'd be like a minute
and a half two minutes in like that but
that nose is just like wrecking Hulk ah
that makes sense to me in the comics but
it depends on what what what comic
you're reading I mean Thanos and Hulk
only ever really fought fought and like
danos versus Hulk when it was like a
one-on-one battle between you two and it
was a fight in the mindscape so it
wasn't really like real world with
consequences or anything like that it
was the most clickbait story jim Starlin
ever wrote but again it's a great movie
there's this really really cool scene
where he is where we're like they all
they're like whoa hey we got to go to
Tanner to Vaughn we got to go see like
the collector because we have to get the
reality stone and we'll talk about the
soul stone here in a second but they're
like we have to get the reality stone
and when they go and grab the reality
stone they get there and like the place
is kind of in shambles like kind of torn
up a little bit but like fan oohs was
like crushing crushing the collector and
he's these is like kind of taunting him
a little bit and so like Drax tries to
step in Peter quill stops him Gamora
steps in and like goes and like actually
kills Thanos like stabs him through the
neck and stabs him through the chest or
something like that and then like his
voice starts talking and then you end up
finding he used the reality team and
just made it all in illusion and it was
like damn then I was like that's beast
man that's best down-and-dirty
that's Infinity Gauntlet Santos and I
like to see he they grabbed a couple of
things from Infinity Gauntlet like when
he turned people and the children's
blocks things like that
he turns um he turns Drax a destroyer in
to stone and my he just
basta pieces um he turns let's see he
turns mantis into like kind of like
twine ball you know like yarn thing
where she's just kind of like springy
almost like a slinky but yeah it's it's
pretty crazy
the big battle at the end happens in
Wakanda the black order okay so here's
here's the big issue that I had with the
black or the black order and this this I
think is one is like making Marvel's
biggest problems where Marvel doesn't
know what to do with the villains like
what doesn't know how to make great
villains and admittedly I think him if
like he came out and said the story is
about the hero is not about the villains
but sometimes in Marvel Comics the
villains are more interesting than the
heroes like ebony maw is way more
interesting to me than like most of the
superheroes in Marvel Comics like he's a
wildly intriguing character I mean I
would say that that with his whole story
at least in the in the MCU of course
like like all the other members of the
of the the Col obsidian or the
Blackwater whatever you want to call you
never find out what their origins are
and if that's a never even indicate the
Corvus glaive and Proxima midnight are
married ah they're just kind of together
and you know like she saves him from
dying or someone those lines that's
about it
the every mall has telekinesis they
never really show him using magic he
just has telekinesis what made him so
cool in the comics is he had no powers
his power came from his words he would
just kind of in Scenario and just make
you do things that you don't want to do
he's like like imagine the purple man
from Jessica Jones except instead of
emitting pheromones he could just talk
you into doing things and so like that
was that was that was the coolest part
of his character in the comics in the
movie he's just another villain like
that's really all he is like the the the
black order are just more films like
they are Red Skull they are all manner
at school they are Red Skull they are
you know like like oh you know Iron
Monger
you know Obadiah Stane in the first the
first movie they're just your
run-of-the-mill
MCU villains which is kind of
regrettable because you could definitely
turn the the cold like the black order
into something pretty awesome
there is no supergiant she doesn't exist
they simply just call black dwarf the
cold like call up city and that's the
name that he gets when she kind of makes
sense they wouldn't call them black
dwarf because I'm sure people would get
pissed off and you know people like to
complain about stuff so people would get
angry about it you know
okay people wanted a who Peter Dinklage
plays Peter Dinklage does not play pit
Patrol which in hindsight probably
wouldn't have been a good idea anyway he
actually plays Eitri one of the dwarves
that helped to originally build a hammer
of Thor hammer does get Stormbreaker
there's no allusion to beta ray bill
there's nothing to indicate beta ray
bill is there his new hammer
Stormbreaker it's really awesome too
because it's basically the Stormbreaker
hammer uh and then like when he dons it
when he picks it up he he gets the whole
garb of like ultimate for like like what
the energy harness and all that kind of
stuff so it's pretty cool he basically
becomes ultimate 4 in terms of his
appearance weird actually looks badass
it looks better than the way he does and
I always thought ultimate 4 looked
better than like the main Marvel
Universe Thor in terms of like the Oh
physical appearance um okay Red Skull
Red Skull comes back red Red Skull
appears in the movie and it's awesome
like what is it happening is vanos
basically like torturers nebula in front
of Gamora we he's been torturing nebula
for some time but he shows Gamora what
he's been doing with nebula after he
kidnaps Gamora who and everybody's on on
not tightening when they're on nowhere
when the guardians the galaxy got
nowhere um then I was like tortures
nebula in front of for more ultimately
gamora's like okay fine I'll tell you
where the soul stone is it's on some
planet you know unlike like out in the
middle of nowhere but it requires kinda
like a caveat like you have to sacrifice
a soul to get the soul stone and so he
kills Gamora he just throws her over the
edge
and he's ladies crying he's like he's
like sorry about your luck got to do it
and like throws her over the edge and so
she dies and he ends up getting the soul
stone uh but when they arrived there a
guy just like starts talking to them now
this is the cool thing basically the way
the Red Skull reappears is an allusion
to the unseen in Marvel Comics those
guys I don't know what that is and the
original like in in the main Marvel
Universe the original Nick Fury was a
white guy and he basically had a story
called original sin where it turned out
that he had done something I can't read
what it was there was something he'd
done but basically like he uh he took
the eyes of the watcher no I'm sorry you
shot the watcher when The Watcher
realized what he was doing when he was
like the man on the wall I got my stuff
and then he took the eyes of the watcher
and then like his punishment for that
whole thing was the rest of the watchers
throughout the universe multiverse
basically confined him to the moon and
chained him there as the unseen so like
he sees everything like the watcher did
but
really knows about I mean they interact
with him from time to time but like he's
just doomed to be chained to the moon
forever
um when the Red Skull reappears you
don't initially know it's him it's just
the unlit it looks like the unseen who's
kind of a floating you know apparition
or source and then finally like you end
up seeing the Red Skull and like the Red
Skull is like I'm confined here to this
planet like the punishment that I have
to pay is to be here and like to know
everything basically um so that's how
they end up finding out about the
soulstone and all that kind of stuff so
they know so you know basically gets the
soul stone that way um there's some cool
moments I mean it's it's cool to see
that hoes fight the superheroes but it's
a combination I mean it's exactly what I
thought it would be I mean the events
play out differently but it's exactly
what I thought it would be in the sense
it's a combination of Infinity Gauntlet
Jonathan Hickman's infinity and Thanos
quest that's basically what it is
nothing said it is a great film like it
is it is that it is a great movie um I
think it's better than the first
Avengers like I said I still think the
Captain America the Winter Soldier is
better but it is a great film like it is
it is really really a good movie there's
there some great moments there but again
just kind of disappointed about how the
oh by the way Loki dies forgot about
that yeah Loki dies Heimdall dies I
forgot to mention those two things and
like basically everybody else everybody
on the Asgardian ship from Thor Ragnarok
except for Thor dies is essentially yet
ah but still yeah I mean I didn't really
like how they handled because the cool
thing about the Black Order is they
could conceivably V be like villains
under themselves without Thanos pinna
you could do that with them so again
that's not the worst this not the worst
movie ever it's it's a great film like
it's it's a great movie I'm gonna go see
it again on Saturday with comics story
and everybody so I'm really excited for
that but uh yeah it's it's pretty solid
it's it's pretty damn enjoyable but do I
spoil review yeah that's that's kind of
where I stand on things I mean you know
it's like I said I think Captain America
the Winter Soldier is better the Civil
War might be a little bit better than
that but you know at the end of the day
it's it just kind of comes down your own
personal preference I really wish they'd
shown Adam warlock but it looks like we
won't see him the big question I have is
like who's gonna lead all those
superheroes
that's where Captain America might come
in from Jonathan Hickman's infinity as
Captain America might be the one like
marshal all the superheroes together um
Tony Stark might die but he was impaled
by by Thanos so who knows if he might
die but still yeah anyway so
that's my whole spoilery review great
film amazing things happened in it was
it was pretty stellar and yeah I will
catch you all later please
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]